il se bat contre les jets acheter
groupement hospitalier de territoires
qui seront installés au 1er juillet les
personnels yvelinois manifesté à l'appel
des collectifs de défense des hôpitaux
les usagers sont inquiets c'est surtout
quand on voit par exemple à mon goût on
a supprimé la comment le service de
cardiologie qui a été transférée en
partie dans le secteur privé a et
vecmont et dans le secteur public sur
poissy le transport fait que quand on a
des problèmes cardiologiques l'urgence
de proximité est une nécessité
ces regroupements se feront sur deux
pôles dans le nord du département et le
sud
les syndicats craignent un impact sur
les conditions de travail et une
disparition des services de proximité
dans le cas de l'économie de 3 milliards
d'euros qui est envisagé parce que le
préalable de la mise en application de
la loi touraine c'est de faire des
économies c'est hôpital public 3
milliards d'euros c'est l'équivalent de
22 mille postes en france et sur poissy
saint germain en laye l'hôpital de
poissy saint germain en laye ces
cinquante 150 postes dont ils risquent
de disparaître si on ne se mobilise pas
il faut absolument se mobiliser pour
garder nos postes de paramédicaux c'est
à dire les aides soignants à les
ouvriers qui travaillent pour pour
l'hôpital qui ont l infirmière qui
seront impactées partie de la préfecture
le cortège s'est ensuite rendu à la
délégation territoriale de l'agencé
régionale de santé
les syndicats n'excluent pas une
nouvelle mobilisation ce mardi